foreign
[Applause]
it's your Cadence and your accent and
everything like did you have references
did you study like how did you get so
perfectly not anachronistic to that
period and nail it as if you were right
back there
well first of all thank you so much
that's so incredibly kind I um I I mean
I I grew up watching you know Liza
Minnelli as Sally Bowles and Cabaret and
I feel like you know that's such an
important role and uh and film and show
for so many of us and I just felt like I
wanted to hopefully attempt to sort of
yeah get her isms get her cadences
things like that you so do you really
take me back to another era and you're
just so perfectly suited and if you want
to know what I'm talking about look at
this clip
I heard about Josh and I want you to
know that I don't believe a single word
of it my dumb Josh couldn't have killed
Elsa he's too too Divine and I'm never
wrong about people
people thank you and now you're gonna be
working at the club oh I can't wait to
take you into my wing and teach you
absolutely everything that I know Jenny
you don't have to do that no I insist
[Applause]
transportive acting thank you like oh my
God okay so
um you come from Washington you had
chickens yeah is that true yeah yeah we
had a lot of chickens we had chickens
that we named they all had specific
names they would come when they were
called really yeah they were like part
of the family I we raised chickens in
the pandemic um really little baby
chicks I have six of them we gave them
names too yeah and um I I love them so
much they're really sweet they're
magical right they're very lovely really
lovely and then is it true that you got
a tattoo what's that story when when you
we were first tattoo oh my very first
tattoo so I yeah so I had um I had this
best friend when I was younger of course
which they were they fun they were very
fun and I was very introverted and she
had wanted this tattoo for a long long
time meaning we were both 14 and so
she'd been hyper fixating on it for a
couple months and I knew about this us
but she was so scared of the pain
um that me little like introverted
homeschool no friends chicken owning
chicken owning Midwest yeah I almost
said Midwest specific Northwest girl
um I volunteered as tribute to like go
first I was like okay okay I'll get a
tattoo first and I'll tell you if it's
really painful and
and we did it it was my first tattoo
ever it was like a Gateway don't start
you won't by the way I know look at her
beautiful hands I know I'm I'm covered
it's so bad and it's so funny because
I'm like so torn you know now I'm 48 and
a mom of two girls and it all comes full
circle when did you get your first
tattoo and I'm like hey
you don't get to know about that I'm
like
13. did you really yeah
yeah somebody else who's had that yeah
of course so I totally fully understand
your relationship thank you thank you
thank you oh yeah no by the way it's not
something I really recommend this this
person who gave us a tattoo it was like
in somebody's house of course you can't
ordered it online of course he was like
I've been practicing on oranges I think
I'm ready and I was like that sounds
legitimate to me do you still like the
tattoo it's horrendously ugly by the way
so
bad right and the guy was named shock I
should have known every
everything it was supposed to be a blue
well first I got these flowers wait
where did you put it where's your first
here mine's here
why did you put it there I don't know do
you have a reason well I put it there
because I was like I'm only 14 I know my
parents would never let me do this maybe
I have to put it somewhere like if I'm
at the beach they're not gonna see it
logic and then the very next day I was
like Mom can I get a tattoo and what'd
she say she was like No And I was like
okay what would you say if I already got
a tattoo and she was like
let me see it and then she's like okay
it's really cute don't tell your dad and
then I told my dad and he was like it's
really cute don't tell your mom
I love it good cop good cop exactly
exactly okay so is it true you like
weird food combos by the way I love a
weird food combo well my friend Eton
bernath and I we started in the pandemic
together doing this show and we would do
weird food Combos and it's like one of
my favorite things to do and I heard you
might I'm down for anything shall we
proceed
wow take me let's go
[Music]